my name is Sergeant Adam lobsinger
l-o-b-s-i-n-g-e-r I'm the public
information officer for the San
Francisco police department in just a
few minutes Chief William Scott and
district attorney Brooke Jenkins will be
providing an update on the incident at
speaker Nancy Pelosi's office this
morning
all right ladies and gentlemen Chief
William Scott and district attorney
Brooke Jenkins
foreign
can we close that door so we don't get
the noise
welcome
hey good morning
okay we'll go ahead and get started good
morning everybody my name is Chief Bill
Scott with the San Francisco Police
Department
at approximately 2 27 this morning San
Francisco police officers were
dispatched to the residents of speaker
Nancy Pelosi regarding an a priority
well-being check when the officers
arrived on scene they encountered an
adult male and Mr Pelosi's husband Paul
our officers observed Mr Pelosi and the
suspect both holding a hammer the
suspect pulled the hammer away from Miss
Pelosi and violently assaulted him with
it our officers immediately tackled the
suspect disarmed him took him into
custody requested emergency backup and
rendered Medical Aid
the suspect has been identified as 42
year old David de Pepe
Mr Pelosi and Mr de Papi were
transported to a local hospital for
treatment
this is an active
investigation currently being led by the
San Francisco Police Department special
investigations division
we are working closely with our partners
from the FBI the U.S attorney's Office
the U.S Capitol Police and our district
attorney here in San Francisco County
D.A Brooke Jenkins and her team the
motive for this attack is still being
determined Mr de Pepe will be booked at
the San Francisco county jail on the
following charges
attempted homicide assault with the
deadly weapon elder abuse Berkeley and
several several other additional
felonies
before I go any further I'd like to
thank the responding officers for their
Swift action this morning those San
Francisco police officers are officer
Colby wilmes officer Kyle Cagney and
Sergeant Edmund Hoang
I'd also like to thank our emergency
dispatcher Heather Grimes who's standing
here to my left for
a really amazing job
for inquiries regarding Mr Pelosi and
his condition we refer you to the
statement issued by Speaker Pelosi's
office this morning
and with that I'm going to turn it over
to our district attorney Brooke Jenkins
for a few brief comments
and when you say in advance this is what
we know at this time we will update you
further but we will not be able to take
any questions after the statement
thank you Chief Scott and I do want to
commend the San Francisco police
department for their immediate response
to this home and for swiftly making sure
that Mr Pelosi was okay and that the
suspect was apprehended we are working
closely with them right now with respect
to the investigation and will proceed
with the appropriate charges as things
unfold as long as as well as work with
the U.S attorney's office and our
federal Partners thank you
all right thank you all for being here I
know you may have
we'll update you when we get more do you
know how we got into the house that's it
for right now we're not going to take
any questions thank you we our office
will be issuing uh news release
very soon but that's it for now thank
you